then I decided to go alone not with my
partner alone to um have a walk in the
forest bit of like a hike in the snow
which I sometimes do but I felt like you
know it could be nice know get some
fresh air and just be one day myself
alone two 3
hours and that's when I I don't know I
just found the confidence again and
I yeah all the things that I had
achieved previously like you know the
wins I managed to still get to that that
point the po po position Labs some good
race results all that just came to my
mind and I actually remember saying
myself I'm the best in the world like I
I have that much confidence like
straight away like I can do this